PROFESSOR: So one more thing
let's do with this operator.
So we're getting accustomed
to these operators,
and these permutation
operators can also
act on operators themselves.
So that's important.
So consider the
action on operators.
So for example,
an operator B that
acts belonging to
the linear operator
some V, when acting
on V tensor V,
we define two
operators, B1 and B2.
And you define them
in an obvious way,
like B1 acting on
Ui 1 tensor Uj 2.
OK, B as an operator
knows how to act
on every vector on the
vector space capital V.
So when you say 1, you're
meaning that this operator acts
on the first Hilbert space.
So this is equal to B
times Ui 1 tensor Uj 2.
So it just acts on
the first state.
How does it act?
Via B, that is an operator,
in the vector space V.
Similarly, if you have
B2 of Ui tensor Uj 2
you have Ui 1
tensor BUj 2 to OK.
So these are operators that
act either on the first state
or in the second state.
So the permutation operators can
do things to these operators,
as well.
So we can ask a
question, what is P21B--
should I start with one?
Yes, one-- P21 dagger.
Remember, when you ask how an
operator acts on an operator,
you always have the
operator that you're
acting with come from the
left and from the right.
That is the natural way
in which an operator
acts on an operator.
You can think of this
thing as your operator
is being acted upon
as having surrounded
by a [INAUDIBLE]
and a [INAUDIBLE]..
And then when the
states transform,
one transforms with U, one
transforms with U dagger.
So always the action
on an operator
is with a U and a U dagger.
So if you ask how does the
permutation operator act on B,
you don't ask generally what's
the product of P times B.
You ask this question.
This is the question that
may have a nice answer.
Then we'll see that there's
other ways of doing this.
So we want to investigate
this operator.
So what I can do is
let it act Ui, Uj.
So what do we get?
We get P21B1.
Now, P21 dagger, we saw
that it's Hermitian anyway,
so it's just P21.
And now it acts on Ui 1.
I'll put the j here, and Uj 2.
So I let up the
P21 on that state,
and that the moves
the i's and the j's.
Now, B1 acts on the
first Hilbert space.
So now we have P21 and we
have BUj 1 and tensor Ui 2.
Now, P21 is supposed to put the
second state in position one
and the first state
in position two.
So this is Ui 1 BUj 2.
I could put this thing--
BUj 2.
And then you see, oh,
this term is here.
So this is nothing else than
B2 acting on the same state
of the Ui Uj, which means--
I guess I could use
this blackboard--
that P21 B1 P21 dagger is B2.
So it has moved you.
The operator used to act
on the first particle.
Two and one changes the first
particle with the second.
It moved it into the other one.
Similarly, you
could do this also.
Would not be a surprise
to you that P21 B2 P21
dagger is equal to B1.
And you don't have to do
the same argument again.
You could multiply
this equation by P21
from the left and P21
dagger from the right.
These things become one
and one, and the operators
remain on the other
side and gives you this.
So this second equation comes
directly from the first.
You don't have to go
through the arguments.
So what is the
use of this thing?
You may have a
Hamiltonian, and you
want to understand
what it means to have
a symmetric Hamiltonian.
And these operators
allow you to do that.
So for example, you may
have an operator O 1,2.
What is an operator O 1,2?
It's an operator build on things
that act on one or act on two.
So if you want to
imagine it, it could
be an O that depends
on the operator
A acting on the first
label, an operator B acting
on the second label, an
operator C on the first label,
an operator D on
the second label.
Could be a very complicated
product of those operators
acting on all kinds of labels.
Now suppose you act with
P21 O 1,2 P21 dagger.
Now, the great advantage of
having a P and a P dagger
acting on a string
of operators is
that it is the same as
having a P and a P dagger
acting on each one.
Remember, if you have
like P and P dagger,
and it's a unitary
operator on ABC,
it's the same as PAP dagger,
PABP dagger, PCP dagger.
It's like acting on each one.
So when you have this P21
P21 dagger acting on this,
it's as if each one of those is
surrounded by a P21 P21 dagger.
So each label one will
become a label two,
and each label two will
become a label one.
And therefore, this operation
is going to give you O2,1
for an arbitrary operator
acting on these two labels.
Now, it may happen that
the operator is symmetric
if O is symmetric.
By that, we mean O
2,1 is equal to O 1,2.
If that happens--
if that happens--
then from this equation you
would have P21 O 1,2 P21 dagger
is O1,2 is itself.
And you could multiply
by a P21 from the right,
giving you P21 O 1,2 equal O
1,2 You're multiplying by a P21
from the right that
cancels this P21 dagger.
P21.
And there you see that
an operator is symmetric
if it commutes with the
permutation operator.
So if always symmetric, this
is true, and this is true,
and then finally, P21 with
O 1,2 commutator is 0.
Oops.
Too low.
Let me see.
It's a commutator.
It's 0.
So that's basically how you
manipulate these operators
on this Hilbert space.